en esta enorme nevera Rafael guarda la
comida de cuatro refugios sociales no
solo tenemos que alimentar a la gente
que está aquí tenemos más que alimentar
tienen de casi todo pero le preocupa la
falta de un alimento fundamental los
huevos
ayer teníamos que haber recibido 180.000
pero solo recibimos 120
de uno de nuestros donantes en
Pensilvania
Si antes una docena de huevos costaba
alrededor de 4 dólares ahora supera los
9 y eso ha provocado que disminuyan las
donaciones por eso hoy se distribuirán
menos en el resto de los centros que
dependen de este refugio
Si ves huevos cocidos el martes y
hacemos huevos revueltos el domingo
solíamos cocinar huevos tres veces a la
semana pero ahora hemos tenido que
recortar porque tenemos que asegurarnos
que todos nuestros centros tienen huevos
estoy haciendo avena con banano Rafael
compensa la falta de proteína del huevo
con otros Alimentos como la crema de
maní o la tocineta opciones menos sanas
pero más económicas los huevos se han
convertido en mercancía de contrabando
con México desde California hasta Texas
los agentes fronterizos han tenido al
menos 2.000 encuentros en el último mes
con personas que trataban de introducir
este alimento en los Estados Unidos y
todo porque allí en México es más barato
una caja de 30 huevos cuesta solo 3
dólares y medio Los Altos precios
también afectan a restaurantes como el
de Benjamin por mucho tiempo no teníamos
y tuve que conducir a diferentes lugares
de long island upstate Nueva York sólo
por encontrar huevos según el
departamento de agricultura en el 2022
cada persona consumió una media de 278
huevos
uno diario
es alimento estrella de los
estadounidenses y muchos locales El
sándwich de huevo y queso es el más
vendido aquí Así que ha sido duro la
peor parte se la llevan los más
desfavorecidos las alternativas al huevo
no siempre cubren Todas las necesidades
y según los expertos pueden pasar varios
meses hasta que los precios de este
alimento vuelvan a estabilizarse